(siren wails)
- [Interviewer] All right, Tameka.
Tameka, where are you from originally?
Where did you grow up?
- Well I grew up a lot
of different places.
I was in placement for a long time.
So, like, I grew up in
L.A. and Long Beach.
And like...
- [Interviewer] Southern California?
- Yeah, the high desert too.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your family.
Did you have both your parents as a kid?
- No. I just met my dad like
six months ago.
Or something like that.
And my mom been dead since I was six.
- [Interviewer] You
lost your mom early on?
- Yeah, she been dead for like 20 years.
- [Interviewer] Who raised you?
- First, my aunty and then
I went back into the system.
I was in group homes and
foster homes and stuff.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- I mean,
It was different.
Like no parents and shit.
It's whatever though.
- [Interviewer] Any abuse or
anything traumatic happen?
- No. I just was
I don't know
you know, different I guess.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
And you went on your own at what age, 18?
- Yeah, 18, but I got
pregnant at 18 though.
So
I was like
I was still in the foster home
I was like damn, I'm about
to have a baby and shit.
So I tried to like, you
know, do shit different.
Do shit right, you know.
But that shit didn't last for long.
Then I had two more kids
and it was just too much.
It was hectic like.
- [Interviewer] So you
have three children?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Are you raising them?
- They live with their dad.
- [Interviewer] They live with dad?
Do you still see them?
- Yeah I see them.
- [Interviewer] You do? Good.
- But you know, like his
mom, she don't like me.
So, they don't be cool like that.
They be trippin' and stuff.
I be like you know,
I be ready to fight.
Cause it's wrong.
So, I don't know.
I just don't, I don't got
I don't got no job or nothing, shit.
What the fuck.
What else I'm supposed to do, you know?
I don't know, so.
I just was like, fuck it.
My homegirl was telling me some shit like
you could just get money
like this you know?
And I'm like shit, fuck
it, let's get money.
So, I just been getting money ever since.
I don't see no
I don't know.
I'd be willing to work and stuff but like,
shit don't happen like that.
Especially
with people like me.
- [Interviewer] Did
you finish high school?
- No.
Cause I mean, I got pregnant.
I tried to go but then it got hectic
and I couldn't find
nobody to watch my baby.
And I was pregnant too.
Already had a baby and I was pregnant..
You know, so
I just stopped going.
- [Interviewer] You started
working the street at what age?
- When I was 18.
- [Interviewer] 18.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Did you work
with a pimp or on your own?
- My homegirl told me about it.
And I just, I never
I always try to stay away from pimps.
I got kidnapped before, but
shit that shit was crazy.
I didn't think they was
really out here like
kidnapping bitches and shit.
That shit was so crazy.
Shit was scary but
I still gotta get money, feel me?
I just try to be a
little bit more careful.
- [Interviewer] It's a dangerous
way to make money, right?
- Yeah it is, but hey.
People be going to war with guns and stuff
so like that's dangerous
way to make a living too.
- [Interviewer] Have you
had some bad experiences?
- Besides getting kidnapped,
no, not really.
I kinda just like
I don't know, I'll be like
two seconds from danger
I'll be fine and I'll like
Oh, I coulda just been
right there, you know.
For something to happen.
I seen a lot of shit though.
I don't do that shit.
That shit is crazy out here like.
Man.
You don't even know.
Cause you know, to see it and to live it
is two different things, you know.
- [Interviewer] What's the
craziest thing you've seen?
- The craziest thing I seen?
- [Interviewer] Well, you
avoided the terrible stuff
but I'm sure you've
probably seen some stuff?
- Yeah, like I've avoided a lot.
I was with my friend one time
and she was like let's go
with this guy or whatever.
And I was like, hell no,
I am not going with that motherfucker.
You shouldn't go either.
I don't know, she got
stabbed up and stuff.
Like a gang of shit.
And I was like damn.
I felt bad, but I told
this bitch not to go.
That's crazy. People is crazy.
I was scared though cause
I coulda been right there.
I was just right there with her, you know.
That shit was, ooh.
I was like man, that shit is crazy.
I was like damn, you know.
Cause if I had went, who knows, you know?
- [Interviewer] You have
to use your intuition.
- Hell yeah.
Ya better.
- [Interviewer] How many
customers do you just say
no thank you?
(laughs)
- Yeah, like lately, like a lot.
People's been crazy out here.
I don't know.
I been trying to work off the internet.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry?
- I been trying to like
work off the internet.
Like on Facebook.
Whatever.
- [Interviewer] Have you
been arrested before?
- Yeah.
I been arrested here, and Las Vegas.
Gang of times in Las Vegas.
- [Interviewer] So you go
to Vegas sometimes too?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
make more money there?
- Yeah.
But I mean, I make a lot of money so.
- [Interviewer] What
do you make in a night?
- Like anywhere from eight to twelve.
I be makin' money.
- [Interviewer] And you'll
work what hours roughly?
- Really like the night
cause I like the night.
- [Interviewer] So you start at what time?
- At like seven.
- [Interviewer] Until what time?
- Until five.
- [Interviewer] And the guys
you'll pick up will be drunk?
- I don't really like to
do it with drunk people.
(laughs)
Unless it's dry or something.
- [Interviewer] You're customers
are white, black, Mexican?
- It don't matter,
just as long as they got some money.
Enough money.
- [Interviewer] How old are your kids?
- My oldest is eight
and my son after him will be seven.
And my baby will be six this September.
- [Interviewer] I mean
eventually they'll be old enough
to figure out what Mom's doing?
- Hopefully like I'd have made it by then.
And I ain't gonna...
- [Interviewer] You'll have made it out?
- Yeah and I ain't gotta.
They ain't gotta know that.
- [Interviewer] Are drugs
part of the picture for you?
- No, I tried to pop pills before
but drugs, no.
I smoke weed though a lot.
- [Interviewer] And you've
not worked with pimps?
- No, I just try to stay away from pimps.
Especially after I got kidnapped.
Shit is crazy. Fuck that.
- [Interviewer] Does this lifestyle
get you depressed sometimes?
You get down?
- [Tameka] Hell yeah, all the time.
I drink a lot.
- [Interviewer] You drink a lot?
- [Tameka] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you have to be drinking
in order to even do this?
- [Tameka] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Are you saving money?
- [Tameka] I'm trying.
- [Interviewer] You spend
it as fast as you make it?
- [Tameka] I been working on that.
- [Interviewer] I've talked
to a lot of the girls
that do this and they say
that they're addicted to the lifestyle.
- [Tameka] I wouldn't say I'm addicted
but I would say like
it's a little bit more than recreation.
- [Interviewer] What do you think
most people don't understand about
girls that do this for a living?
- [Tameka] I mean, cause they don't know.
What it's like to have nothing.
Like absolutely nothing.
Oh, what I'm gonna do? Nothing?
Like nothing?
You know what I'm saying?
I didn't have nothing.
Don't even think about
it cause you got nothing.
You know what I'm saying?
And people don't know that shit.
They don't know what that shit feel like.
They don't have a lot
to say on how they feel
I should be or she should be
or whoever should be
when they don't even know.
Cause if they knew, they
wouldn't even say that.
I know they wouldn't say that
cause I wouldn't say that.
And I know.
- [Interviewer] When your
back's against the wall?
- [Tameka] Yeah, you
know, that's crazy but
- [Interviewer] You have no other options.
It becomes an option.
What was the best time of your life?
- I think when my oldest son was born.
Yeah.
I was happy.
I was real happy.
- [Interviewer] And
what was the worst time?
- Probably right now.
- [Interviewer] Right now?
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- I'm 26.
- [Interviewer] 26?
You ever stand back and
just look at your life
and go man, this is nuts?
- Yeah, like this ain't
what I planned for it to be.
- [Interviewer] Did you envision
a different life for yourself?
- Hell yeah.
I always knew where I was gonna be.
When I was younger as a kid.
I don't know.
I wanted to be like a journalist and shit.
All kind of shit.
When I grew up and reality was real
it was like,
it was for real.
- [Interviewer] Well but
you're still very young too.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you find this lifestyle
gets in the way of romantic
relationships for you?
- I just gave up on romantic relationships
cause they don't even
make sense to me nomore.
- [Interviewer] If your
mom had not passed away
at such a young age,
do you think that might've steered you...
- It would've been different.
- [Interviewer] Are you finding
the line that you'll draw
as what you'll do and won't do changing
as the years go by?
- No, I'm pretty firm on what I believe.
- [Interviewer] You'll
stand by what you do?
And where do you see your
life going from here?
I mean you're 26.
Do you see getting out as a possibility?
- I hope so.
Yeah, I really hope so.
- [Interviewer] What
do you think would help
a girl in your situation?
To make a change?
- A lot.
Stability.
Really, that's the main thing.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have dreams of anything?
Do you ever fantasize about some life
you can somehow
find?
- [Tameka] I'm trying
not to give up, but shit.
I don't know, I just hope so.
It'll be all right.
One day.
- [Interviewer] All right, Tameka.
Thank you so much for talking with me
and good luck with
wherever you go from here.
You're still very young.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.